Hello, my name is
Gonzalo Tazu and
today we will talk
about the anatomy
and physiology of
the auditory system.
So, today's objective
is to describe
the anatomy of the
outer, middle and
inner ear. Then we
will describe the
principles of
mechanotransduction.
Then we will review
the anatomy of
the auditory pathway
from the inner
ear to the primary
auditory cortex.
We'll describe the
physiology of the primary
auditory cortex, and
we'll look at the
different types of
auditory dysfunction,
conductive versus
sensorineural hearing
loss, and we'll give
examples of both.
So this is the ear.
So the ear, we divide
the ear in three parts.
This is the outer
ear that captures the
sound pressure that's
coming from outside
and channels into the
middle ear. So here
the sound waves are
traveling through air.
Now in here they are
going to impinge onto
the tympanic membrane
and now on the other
side is the middle ear
now these vibrations
this air pressure
vibration is going to
convert it into vibrations
through the ossicles
that are going to
propagate the wave, and
this will be transmitted
to the cochlea.
Here, the sound
wave is going to
be traveling in
liquid and will
be converted into
nerve impulses.
The sound pressure
is very, very
extremely low. It's
10 to the 8th times
weaker than the
atmospheric pressure.
So, there is a physical
problem that the
auditory system
needs to solve, which
is how to convert
such small pressures
into nerve impulses
in a reliable manner.
So, in the middle
ear, we have the
tympanic membrane
and the othicules.
So, we have here
the ear canal where
the sound pressures
are going to
make, cause vibrations
in the tympanic membrane.
Now, the bones
of the middle
ear, we have the malleus,
it's the hammer,
when they have the
incus, and then
we have the stapes.
These bones are
the smallest bones
in the human body.
So the vibration of
the tympanic membrane
first goes through
the malleus, then that
vibration is transmitted
to the incus, and
finally that gets
transmitted through the
stapes into the cochlea.
And this pressure
is going to be applied
on the oval window.
Now, these obstacles,
although the wave,
the sound pressure
is now going to be
transmitted to this
solid, this cavity
needs to be filled with
air. So if liquid
will appear here,
the sound transmission
will be impaired.
So the problem that
the air needs to solve
is that the sun will
live in air. and
sound waves travel
through air now but our
bodies are mostly
formed with liquid and
the hair cells the the
transduction of sound
pressure of vibration
to nerve impulses
are in liquid so
the airways do not
********* well into
liquids you can next summer
when you are at the
pool go and you put
your head under water
you'll notice that
sounds get mitigated
because the sound
pressure the sound
will not ********* well
into liquid the reason
is that the liquids
are much less compressible
than air so in
order to transmit the
vibration do you need
much higher pressure
so you need to convert
the low pressure
sun wave into higher
pressure such such
wave can be detected in
liquid so the way that
this is happening is
that com is by the
difference in the area
so you can compare
here in the middle here
the very large tympanic
membrane and that
that sound pressure
is going to be applied
to a much smaller
area which is the area
of the oval window
so the forces are
going to be higher and
the pressure will be
increased so we have
a trans a conversion
from low pressure in
air to high pressure
in liquid, performed
by the middle ear.
In the middle
ear, we could
have conductive
hearing loss.
So conditions that
affect the middle ear
conduction could be
damage to the tympanic
membrane, or we can have
fluid in the tympanic
cavity or damage to
the ossicles if the
tympanic membrane would
be perforated then
there's not going to be
a pressure difference
between the ear canal
and the tympanic cavity
so the sound will just
bypass the ossicle
chain and will directly
in pitch on the oval
window so there won't
be any change in there
will be no amplification
in the pressure
and the sound perception
will be highly
attenoid also if liquid
accumulates inside the
tympanic cavity the
ossicles could not move
well, their movement
will be dampened and
will perceive a decrease
in sound intensity.
So the transmission
through the ossicles
is not completely
passive. There is
a certain amount
of control. There
are two sets of
muscles that serve to
attenuate the
intensity of the sound
transmitted through
this ossical chain.
One of the muscles
is the tensor
tympanic muscle,
which is innervated by
cranial nerve
number five. You can
see that if you
contract this muscle,
the malleus will
uncouple from
the tympanic membrane and
there will be
sound attenuation.
The second muscle that
could mitigate the
transmission of
sound is the small
muscle, the stapedius
muscle, which is
innervated by cranial
nerve number 7. So this
muscle, you can see
when it contracts,
this step is going to
decouple from the oval
window and it will
reduce the intensity of
the transmitted cell.
The purpose of these
muscles is to protect
the very frail inner
hair cells from high
pressures produced by
loud sounds. So, there
are reflexes that when
a strong sound is
perceived, these muscles
will contract, and
the amount of energy
transmitted to the hair
cells will be reduced.
Still, sudden
loud sounds can
still damage
the hair cells.
so now we will
describe the principles
of mechanotransduction
in the inner ear
so sound comes
transmitted through the
bothicles to the oval
office and it travels
through the cochlea and
then it's transmitted
into nerve impulses
the cochlea is located
in the petrous portion
of the temporal
bone it has 2.5 turns
and is about the size
of a chip also the
diameter decreases with
each coil in order
to understand the
structure of the cochlea
let's start with this
simple diagram so we
have the oval window
and on the other side
at the output of the
cochlea will have the
round window so as
we saw the steps couples
to the oval window
now between the oval
window and the round
window we can locate
here the basilar
membrane the basilar
membrane is going
to be the place
where you're going to
find the hair cells
now we have the
structure and now
imagine that you elongate
this middle um um
this um middle cavity
elongated and
twisted and we have a
cochlea so the reason
that the um that we
have this elongation
is to have different
resonant mechanical
resonant frequencies
of the cochlea So
there's differences
between the apex
and the base of the
cochlea. So the base
is closer to where the
stapes brings the
vibrations into the
oval window, and
the apex is the more
distal part. The basilar
membrane is wide,
thin, and floppy
at the apex of the
cochlea, but it is
narrow, thicker,
and more taut
towards the bass.
The bass responses
to high frequencies,
and the apex is going
to be responding to
lower frequencies. So,
you might think that
this as a guitar,
where you have high
tension, that's going to
be resonating at higher
frequencies, and
lower tension is going
to cause resonance
at lower frequencies.
So, the role of
the cochlea is to
decompose the vibration
into its frequency
components. As you
are aware, sound is
composed, can be
decomposed into a sum
of sine waves of
different frequencies.
Human hearing rate
is between 20 hertz
and between 16 and 20
kilohertz, depending
on your age. and
the stiffness of the
basilar membrane
determines the location
of which frequency
the basilar membrane
is going to oscillate
to. So you are
converting, so you get
a continuous wave and
you are going to
decompose it mechanically
into the different
frequencies,
depending which part
of the basilar membrane
the oscillation is
going to be largest.
Notice also that the
diameter of the cochlea
is reversed to that of
the basilar membrane.
At the oval window,
the cochlea is
broadest and the basilar
membrane is at its
narrow, and the opposite
is true at the apex.
Let's look at the
anatomy of the cochlea.
So the air impinges
onto the tympanic
membrane, that vibration
is transmitted through
the ossicles, the
force is applied on
the oval window. Now
we are on the couplet.
So here the wave is going
to travel through liquid,
in this case
the perilymph,
this first chamber is
the Scala vestibuli,
the sound makes the
turn, and now we are
going to be into the
Scala tympanic, the wave
will come out through
the round window. So
that's the pathway of
the vibration traveling
to liquid. So this
liquid is going to be
the perilymph. So here
in the middle, we have
the organ of Corti,
which has its tectorial
membrane. And here,
the liquid is not going
to be perilymph, and
it's going to be the
endolymph, which has
different properties.
So, if we now cut
through the cochlea,
a transversal section,
we can see the
scala vestibuli and
the scala tympanic.
And here, there is
the cochlear duct
where the endolymph
is located. So, what
is important is here,
surrounded by this
endolymph, we have the
tectorial membrane,
and there is the
bacillar membrane
and the organ of
Corti, and here, very
small, you can see
the hair cells, and
here is where the
hair cells send their
output through the
cochlear nerve. Now,
the endolymph has
high potassium
concentration in the
extracellular medium.
So this is very
unique in most of the
nervous system. The
concentration of potassium
is low extracellularly.
But here in the
endolymph, surrounding
the hair cell tips,
the concentration of
potassium is high.
The perilymph,
the concentration
of potassium is
close to what
you are used to,
low potassium.
So this is a picture
of the organ of
Corti, we have the
tectorial membrane, and
there are two types
of hair cells, they
are the inner hair
cells and the outer
hair cells. The outer
hair cells are not
coupled to the
tectorial membrane, and
they are the actual
sensory receptors.
And 95% of the
fibers of the
auditory nerve
that project to the
brain arise from
this population.
So the outer hair cells
actually make contact
with the tectorial
membrane, and they
receive efferent
terminal. so they are
there's a feedback
loop here where there's
movement of the tectorial
membrane and also
the hair cells the
outer hair cells are
producing movement as
well so the stereocilia
are where the sound
mechano-electrical
transducers are
located and are in here
on the top of the
inner hair cells.
So there are three
outer hair cells. This
is an electron microscope
image showing the
outer hair cells and
here the inner hair
cells. There is one row
of inner hair cells and
there are three rows
of outer hair cells.
What is important and
really something to
remember is that the
number of inner hair cells
is very small it's
only 3500 inner hair
cells total so so each
one comes and dead of
these inner hair cells
this can affect hearing
and they do not regenerate
and this this is
a very slow a small
number right so in the
brain you know science
we're used to millions
hundreds of thousands
but for ourselves the
number is really small
so the uh stereocilia
are connected through
these structures
called tiplinks so these
timblinks functionally
coupled they are
functionally coupled to
mechano-electrical
transduction channel so when
they move the channels
open and stretch of
this stereocilia causes
the opening of this
mechanoelectric
transduction
channel this met channels
so what hair cells
actually do is to detect
the flexions of the
basilar membrane so
the outer hair cells,
the tips of the
stereocilia are embedded
in the tectorial
membrane. So when the
tectorial membrane is
moved because of the
vibrations in the
cochlea, that movement
is going to be
transmitted through the
inner hair cells. So
that vibration is what
causes the inner hair
cells to move in
this diagonal manner.
The inner hair cells
are not coupled
and not directly
mechanically connected
to the tectorial
membrane, but
the movement of
the stereocilia is
induced by movement
of this endoleaf.
Now the hair cells
synapse onto the
spiral ganglion cells.
One spiral ganglion
cell connects to
one inner hair cell.
The hair cells
depolarize when they are
activated, but they do not
fire action potentially
as release glutamate,
which is going to
be affecting the spiral
ganglion neurons.
So the action of
the spiral ganglion
neurons for cranial
nerve number
There are also
efferent axons
innervating
the hair cells.
So,
if we now look at an
individual
inner hair cell,
surrounding the
stereocilia, they
are surrounded
by the endolymph,
and there is
high potassium.
When the mechanosensory
trigger channels,
when the hair cells,
the stereocilia move,
This movement causes
the opening of these
potassium channels,
and potassium flows in,
which is very unique.
Remember,
potassium usually
flows out of the cell.
In this case, in this
particular case, because
of the characteristic
of the endolymph,
the potassium
flows into the
cell and causes
the polarization.
Now, toward the cell
body of the inner
hair cell, that's the
peri-lymph, and here,
the polarization
produced by potassium
in the stereosellular
causes inflow of
calcium. This inflow
of calcium is going
to cause the opening
of calcium-activated
potassium channels,
and here the
potassium will flow
outside of the cell to
bring back the potassium
down to resting.
So very important
is how the potassium
concentration is
regulated for hearing.
so now let's look at the
anatomy of the
auditory pathway
so the ascending
starts in the
cochlea in the
neurons in the
spiral ganglion
that are going to
receive input from the
inner hair cells and
send their axons into
the ipsilateral
cochlear nucleus in the
rostral medulla here
the actions of the
cochlear the of the
cochlear nucleus are going
of the neurons here
are going to ascend
to the midpoints
here is the midpoints
where the fibers are
going to decussate and
continue their their
their trip towards
the thalamus so it's
important to notice
that some fibers are
going to make synapses
in the superior
body complex in the
midpoints some other
fibers are going to
so you have input from
one ear so you have
fibers that are going
decusating here at
the mean midpoints, and
there are structures
there that are going
to have information
coming from both
ears. So by comparing
the difference,
subtle difference and
intensity and timing
of the input from both
ears, that's going
to help us for sound
localization. So the
circuitry for that
sound localization is
located here in the
superior olivari complex
in the midpoints.
So the fibers are
going to ascend through
the lateral lemniscus.
After the decusation
in the midpoints,
this information is
going to reach the
inferior colliculus.
From the inferior
colliculus, they are
going to be projections
to the medial
genicular body the
mgp of the thalamus
bilaterally and this
is going to be the
auditory thalamus from
there the thalamic
neurons are going
to project to the
auditory cortex in
the temporal lobe
so besides this ascending
pathway there is
also olivocochlear
descending pathways and
there are two major
subsystems the medial
component is made of
myelinated axons of the
medial superior olive
projecting to the cochlear
outer hair cells and
there is also a lateral
component made up of
unmyelinated axons
of neurons of the
lateral superior olive
projecting to the cochlear
nerve fiber near the
afferent synapses with
the cochlear inner hair
cell so the outer hair
cells are going to
receive myelinated
feedback fast feedback
the inner hair cells
that feedback signal it's
slower traveling through
a myelinated axis
so let's now describe
the basic physiology
of the nucleus of the
central auditory net
as well as of the
primary auditory cortex.
So we thought
that the cochlea
mechanically is going to
divide the different
components,
low frequencies and
high frequencies,
depending on which
part of the cochlea is
going to resonate.
And that tonotopy is
actually preserved
also in the primary
auditory cortex in
the temporal lobe.
So the more rostral
part of the auditory
cortex is going to
represent the lower
frequencies, and the
more caudal part is
going to represent
higher frequencies.
so here this is a
very unique example
of recordings of
single cortical neurons
in a human person
so as you are
aware there are several
types of epilepsy
that originate in
the temporal lobe.
So people,
when the surgeons
want to find the
location of the fosce
that is originating
that epilepsy,
sometimes they implant
electrodes into
the temporal lobe.
Some of those
electrodes are going to
be in the auditory
cortex. So these
researchers were able
to record cortical
neurons in humans. And
what was noticeable
is they play different
frequencies. And
what you can see is
the exquisite frequency
tuning. So this
neuron doesn't respond
to 900 hertz, doesn't
respond to 1130, but
it only responds to
1110 hertz. So there's
a very high precision
in the human auditory
cortex for frequency
representations.
Now we will look at
the different type
of conductive versus
sensory neural
hearing loss, and we'll
provide some examples
of how audition
can be affected in
different conditions
and how the auditory
function is tested
by clinicians. So,
hearing loss is
divided generally by,
it can be conductive,
which will be
anything that blocks
the conduction of
sound from the external
and middle ear.
This is a
mechanical problem
that is often
correctable.
And sensory neural, which
involves the inner ear,
cochlea, or the
auditory nerve, and is
usually caused by
hair cell pathology.
Now, in general, there's
no treatment, but
in recent years for
this sensory neural,
cochlear implants have
been used in this. A
cochlear implant is an
array of electrodes is
implanted in the
cochlea, and there is an
external microphone, an
electronic device converts
the sound captured by
the microphone into
divided according to
the frequency, depending
on the location of the
cochlea, and converts
that into electrical
impulses. so it
bypasses the middle in
the middle ear and it
bypasses the the
transduction in the cochlear
directly is going to
stimulate the cochlear
nerve um but several
of them have been used
and technology is
improving increasing the
density of electrodes
and so on now there's
also mixed loss which
is a combination
of sensory neural and
conductive hearing
loss so what are the
causes of conductive
hearing loss and it could
be congenital atresia
or malformation of
the external auditory
canal in this case
for example in this
example the external
ear is properly formed
but this person its
ear canal is blocked.
Congenitally, it's
unilateral in the majority
of cases and children
with unilaterally
or allatricially typically
have normal speech
as long as the other
ear is unaffected.
There's also the
possibility that this could
be also associated
with malformation of
the ossical but there
are surgical treatments
available and there's
a possibility uh
that in there's an
increased risk of delay
language development
due to the functional
mono-outal hearing and
so early identification
is essential another
cause of conducting
hearing loss loss would
be scam cell carcinoma
that blocks the ear
canal here is an
otoscopic image you
can see here the tumor
and here in a CAT scan
you can see that the
ear canal is completely
blocked so there
will be a hearing loss
conductive hearing loss
on the in this ear
another cause of
conductive hearing loss
could be eustachian tube
dysfunction so you
have an infection which
are viral upper
respiratory or sinusitis
the eustachian tube
can get blocked so the
eustachian block tube
provides the drainage
of the of the middle
ear so without if that
drainage is blocked
then liquid can
accumulate in the middle
ear and if there is
liquid accumulation the
vibrations transmitted
to the ossicles will
be affected also the
middle ear barotrauma
could also cause this
chamber to fill with
a thorough fluid or
blood which also is
going to affect hearing
other other causes
of conductive
hearing loss
include osteoma
malformation of the
ossicles otosclerosis,
benign polyps,
and colosteomas,
or cerumen impactation.
Sensory neural
loss refers to
hearing loss in
the cochlear and
above. It could
be congenital,
so it can be hereditary,
autosomal dominant, or
recessive, like Asher
syndrome, or it could
be non-hereditary
caused by infection,
recreational drug use,
alcohol,
and retinoid acid.
Presbycusis is the
age-related hearing
loss, especially
high frequencies.
Remember, there
is only a discrete
amount of inner hair
cells, and as they
die, as we age,
we lose hearing,
specifically in the
high frequencies.
so there is also
meningitis and metals can
destroy inner hair
cells and cause deafness
very important
noise exposure it
also can damage the
cochlear structures
also for the
high frequencies
a tumor most commonly
this neuromus
could also cause
could affect the
cochlear nerve and
produce hearing loss.
Another cause
could be anorchiali
malformation, where the
tonsil of the cerebellum
impinge on trinal
nerve number eight,
producing hearing loss.
And also there's a
very several
medications, antibiotics,
and chemotherapeutics,
high-dose aspirin,
anti-malarial agents
that could also lead
to hearing loss so
asher syndrome is a
hereditary form of
hearing and vision loss
the most serious type
is type one so from
birth there is profound
deafness on both
ears and vision is
also affected there is
decreased night vision
before age 10 and
vestibular function the
balance is also there
are also problems with
it since birth the
type 2 and type 3
are less severe Usher
syndrome can be produced
by several mutations
that are going to
be affecting the tip
links from the stereocilia.
So, there could
be several genes like
MY07A, USH1C, CDH23,
PCHD15, and SANS.
These genes create this
wonderful mechanical
transduction system.
So, as you can see,
the steam leaks are
very delicate, and
these genes of this
molecular machinery is
very unique, and there
is not much redundancy.
So, if you have
a mutation, let's
say, of cadetine 23,
this typically is going
to be affected, and
the MET channel will
not open when these
stereocilia are vibrating
due to the vibrations
in the cochlea.
So, these genes play a
role in the development
and maintenance of
the stereocilia for
Asher syndrome type
1. A second type of
sensorineural hearing
loss is the epilepsy,
ataxia, sensorineural
deafness, and
tubulopathy, EAST
syndrome, EAST, which
is produced by
mutations in KCNJ10.
So this gene codes
for the cure 4.1
potassium channel.
As you remember,
the regulation of
potassium is very important
for normal hearing
and also for in the
kidney and in the
brain. So that without
mutations in the KIR
4.1 potassium channel,
we are going to have
the epilepsy when it's
affecting the brain
and ataxia as well,
sensory neural deafness
because its role in
the inner ear and the
tubulopathy because
of its role in the
kidney. So here, for this
lecture, we'll focus
on what happens in the
hair cell. Remember,
the endolive has to
have high potassium
concentrations to go into
the stereocilia. So
cure 4.1 participates
in the generation and
maintenance of high
potassium concentrations
in the endolive.
without high potassium
concentrations the inner
hair cells will not
depolarize so this is
a recessive genetic
disorder you can see
here that in this
family pedigree it only
appears at the end on
these patients and there
is also this hearing
loss in these people
So, tinnitus is most
commonly described
as a high-pitched
continuous tone,
it's caused by
hyperactivity of the
cochlear amplification
produced by
the outer hair
cells, and frequently
this is the
first sign of a
lesion that is
causing hearing
loss, especially
sensory neural.
Another cause for
sensorineural healing
loss is a vestibular
schwannoma.
This is a slow-growing
tumor of the vestibular
cochlear nerve. Here
you can see an image
of it. This is a benign
tumor, but it can
cause damage to
surrounding structures as
it grows, including
the facial nerve. So
remember, and then this
is something to watch
during your neuroanatomy
lab, you should see
that the cochlear
nerve and the facial
nerve run very close to
each other. So a tumor
that is growing in the
vestibular cochlear
nerve will also cause
pressure into the
facial nerve, and there
will be some facial
nerve-associated
pathologies. So the symptoms
of this vestibular
schwannoma are vertigo,
hearing loss,
and tinnitus.
It's usually diagnosed
using an MRI of
the brain, and the
treatment is surgical.
But given its location,
their possibility
of the complication
could include
hearing loss and
paralysis of the
facial muscles.
so the ear and auditory
testing could be done
through otoscopic exam
pure tones are played
right to see in which
part of the cochlea
might be affected
there's also a testing
for speech comprehension
there are tests of
the middle ear to measure
the timpanometry and
the acoustic reflect
testing we can also
directly measure auditory
brainstem responses
this is used for
example in little babies
where we cannot ask them
if they hear a sound
however we can still
measure the uh electrical
evoked potential in
the brainstem we can
also directly measure
the acoustic emission
so when the the efferent
copies or efferent
signals cause the the
basilar membrane, the
membrane to vibrate,
then that can be heard,
and there is also the
Weber and ring test.
So,
for the ring test,
these tests are
designed to determine
if its hearing
loss in an ear is
sensorineural or if
it's conductive.
For the ring test,
we will have a
tuning fork which
is placed against
the mastoid bone.
So, in that case,
as this tuning fork
is pressed through
the mastoid bone,
there's going to be
conduction not through
the ear canal but
through the bone.
and once the subject
so the the amplitude
produced by the tuning
fork will will be
reduced in time at
some point the subject
will not hear any sound
anymore and at that
point uh the tuning
fork is moved away
and close to the ear
now we are not using
bone conduction we are
using air conduction
and then because air
conduction has is
more efficient than um
than bone conduction
then the subject
should report that
the sound has restarted
again if it does
not restart this
would indicate
conductive hidden loss
in that ear for the
weather test the
tuning fault is located
here on the top of the
head, and the subject
should indicate
that the, and this
person has some complaint
of hearing loss,
it should say that
the tuning fork is
localized to the affected
ear. So this would
mean that the bone
conduction is able to
create vibrations in
the cochlea of affected
ear so the cochlea
is intact and this
person has conducted
hearing loss however
if the sound is localized
to the non-affected
ear then that means
that there is a
sensory neural hearing
loss in that ear so
the anatomy of the
auditory system includes
the ear outer middle
and inner as well
as diverse central
nuclei of the brainstem
and thalamus, and
finally the neocortex.
Audition emerged from
mechanotransduction
and synaptic
transmission along the
auditory pathway,
and this function
of mechanotransduction
or synaptic
transmission probably
causes hidden loss.
Thank you very much
for your attention.